Quế năm, lần trước khi bống thì biên đắt chia tay dần bị báo nhất quả phải lọ, nào vẻ xe,
quả tết, đồ đặt, chỉ vì sinh hà thằng này,
bệ dân thọng đăng chi tiêu như thế thảo cho hợp lý trung mô cao đều là này của mình khám phát xem nhé.
Bộ năng chi phía lộn lên rất là nhiều luôn, nào là chực bị quả tác cho hay bên ra đình.
chỉ vì về quen tết, và chỉ vì một sống cung áo, sống dự cho ra đình ngày tết nữa.
Này đi làm của mình thì chi tiêu khá lên đơn giản.
Bởi vì nhà mình cần công ty cho nên không tổng cạnh quản mà, chỉ chuyển nước.
Bởi vì sáng thì mình ăn cũng rất đơn giản, chưa thì mình cạnh đoán của tổng hiệp.
Bởi vì thái đặt đơn giống, vì nhà rất lop biệt.
khi mà đặt đông người thì còn đục xác là nhiều mà,
tính ra mỗi người chỉ chúng mình hỏa lám người thì cũng mình thôn.
Nếu ngày quynh năm khi mà, đây là gì rất là xác,
và rất là nhiều công việc.
Thì bởi tối mình thực trọng của món có trong buộc xúc tập một người ăn mà mình chỉ có 1 nó phút để cho.
Bà giá lại mình nữa.
Và chúng là khi mà ăn một mình thì nên cho 1 những món có trong buộc xúc tập một người ăn mà mình chỉ có 1 nó phút.
Và khi mà đông người thì hay trọng nướng nóm, khi mà đặt đơn giống thì rất sướng và trọng ra hoàn tích kiện.
Vì chỉ vì rất là dễ ngay.
Đói chân này từng mình đã chung, bí ăn được nâng mà, lần từng trong 2 gỡ con con chình chính gỳn,
tích kiểu tất cả các mấy bà đi.
Mình muốn hơi chia đông như chỉ tổn hành là đi thôi.
Cô giống như bà nhiều đồng việc khác thì quay nâng thì mình mọng bị thử lộn luôn.
Đi khi ăn cơ phải gọi là dời nước cả lịch đi họ.
Nào là sinh nhập này, có phát triển này tất liên này chiếc tay này,
cái gì cũng phải hành hành hành của ố, tên mấy khoảng qua cát,
rồi rồi, mình đe nước, lưu tháng 15 triệu mình cứ phải gọi là ử ổ xí lộn.
Hộn này của mình chỉ tiêu chỉ sống quay nâng bữa thôi.
Với sáng, thì mình sẽ uống biên đoạn mình ngọt như là đoạn báo này.
Mình đi, này hoặc là dưới sẽ tự phá ta phê năng đi.
Đi tôi uống chi vuy nhất có thể, xác film tiêu nhẹ thì sẽ gân phát cho bữa chung và bữa tối.
Con chua thì tối hô không mà bật quá thì mình sẽ đặc lua luôn của với đồng nghiệp.
Hôm nào phải nơi gôn tiêu đăng ngoài ăn, nhưng mà cực cho bây giờ mình không phải bị trải tụi quá.
Con bối đồn mới là dưới chi tiêu nhất, các là bối nhóc thì gặp ở ở đủ ta và phát khang.
Quối là nước thì thì mình lại lên app ra vì có dịch bụt là đi ăn là háng.
Bào đầy có rất nhiều dân bục, thì có thể lựu ộn, theo thì bọn món ăn như là lộn này.
Điều này, hay đoạn nhẹt đoạn hàng này,
và có thể chọn theo gì khi là dịp xíng nhẹt này hộn,
để tụt tập ra đi bắt này.
Lâu tiền thì mình sẽ vào ra xuống đủ đean hàng.
Tại sao như một nhà hàng lối bắt mình chọn nhà xin mười,
thì có thể một chất phó chở,
từ quán chỉ cần nói nhìn viên tên toàn qua gói gói app vào chờ là đủ sóng ngô.
Quên năm, ai cũng bận dộn đặc ở thêm nhiều khả phải lò,
khi khi các bạn chứ sẻ thì mình thấy,
ai cũng có kênh siến để chi tiêu hợp lý,
ăn ố gơ đủ chất để vừa hợp tụi tiền.
Thì có bị kiết này không ngay có mọi người.
Sẽ giúp đừng hỏng chúng ta sẽ thở hợp trong mọi chi tiêu quý nào.
Bất mạnh thi ra, bạn đang tiếp kiện mà gích nào.
Hãy có mẹn chứ sẻ của mọi người nhá.